[Music]
it's a real really powerful time for
everybody to get woke Oprah Winfrey
speaks out on the sexual harassment
epidemic in Hollywood
what can the powerful women do to bring
this conversation I love that this I'm
not happy that it happened the way that
it did but this moment is I feel a
seminal moment about the way you view
somebody who has less power than you do
you know this is really a question about
power and the misuse and abuse of power
so I think it's a it's a time for those
of us who do hold some to come together
and to see what we can do to further
this moment that's actually what have
you really been having meetings with
other women in the industry trying to
see what you guys can do and where you
can take it from me I love that can you
share anything I cannot ET spoke with
lady Oh at the Queen sugar season 2
finale event in LA on Tuesday
it's the own Network drama series
created by Ava Duvernay I think we need
to take the spotlight and turn it away
from you know what these very foul kind
of misguided sexist misogynistic like
rapists pedophiles have done and turn it
to the people who have been harmed and
turned that pain into beauty and I think
art is one of the ways to do that and so
many of the women who have been affected
by it have been artists and and so I
encourage and bolster and support women
to find ways to turning that pain in the
beauty I believe I believe we will we've
always done that so it'll happen again
queen sugar has garnered critical
acclaim and high praise for many reasons
among them the decision to feature all
female directors we wanted other people
to take the idea and run
with it and whether it's half a crew or
part of the crew or just makes people
more attuned to OG where where is the
inclusiveness where are the women let's
see who wins
once it's all out in the open
[Music]
you
[Music]